ما حدا فينا بقدر ينكر قديش مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اخذ جزء كبير من حياتنا ونكون
واقعين اكثر كثار فينا بييجي وقت وبياخدوا
فرصه
وبيبتعدوا عنها يعني اجازه نوع من انواع
الاجازه بس هل يا ترى بنقدر نستغني عنها
استغناء تام بصراحه ما بعتقد لانه شو قصه
او لكن قصه الفنانه يسرا
ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي شكلها قصه كبيره
لانه يسرا وخلال تواجدها بلقاء تلفزيوني
شنت هجوم اقل ما يقال عنه انه حاد على
موقع التواصل الاجتماعي ورواتها خلونا
نسمع سؤالك
جوجل
اذا مثل ما شفتوا يا جماعه يسرى ومنتهى
الحده اللي بتخالف اسلوبها اللي احنا
متعودين عليه عبرت عن كرها واشتياقها من
مستخدمين السوشيال ميديا قالت انه بعض
المستخدمين هدفهم انهم يشيطين وافعال
الفنانين والمشهورين ويبينوا حالهم انه هم
الناس اللي مناح ونقطه ثانيه كثير مهمه
حكت عنها يسرى كمان هي انه الجمهور صار عم
يقتحم حياه الفنانين لدرجه خليتها في بعض
المرات تختفي علشان ما يعرفوها وقالت انه
هي مضطره تتحمل وبصراحه ليكون واقعيين
شويه يعني الموضوع بصير في بعض الاحيان
كثير وهذا شيء ما بنقدر ينكره
عاوز